[Music]
well how did I get into this chair again
you're hosting again
I'm so glad oh thanks for having me guys
oh we should we do like a in whatever
news as for old times in porno Easter
eggs news what nice somebody is leaving
porn filled Easter eggs in Florida
mailboxes how do you put porn in an egg
oh it's possible like a thumb drive or a
picture yeah it's possible
I thought I'm gonna be nice you get a
free hard drive free porn
and free born both yeah wholesome course
at first before we get into the porn
question that is the porn scene right
because I'm usually saved oh [ __ ] if we
switch the chairs and then language it
we should guess which chair was Jose by
the way they're acting do we sell I
would I mean when I was Catholic I tell
the great Easter pretty heavily in
school
Easter egg hunts knows about it yeah
Easter eggs and stuff it's - it's like
Christmas is like about having a tree
and the lights and the presents but I
didn't go to church or anything that no
we would have that we every Friday we
couldn't eat meat and then like I would
have to give something up yeah until I
used to like painting the Easter eggs
that's fun and you know in Europe they
actually have Easter eggs like at stores
like it's painted the eggs are paying
the real eggs that you just buy them
painted already I didn't I didn't buy it
I just thought I was like whoa real
Easter eggs like they paint it I could
have seen that here yeah I mean when I
was a kid like my grandma would just
boil the eggs and then she'll just have
us paint over it
yeah there's kids you didn't do it as a
kid no yeah that's what I did oh but I
just saw it at the store right now I was
just it was all you take out all the fun
the fun part is dying
yeah I don't know I just remember like
after we painted they're like okay you
can now enjoy it you steer and I'm like
I'm gonna slip wheels and I got what the
candy inside you do I won't let the
other kids help with the little plastic
eggs then you get like friggin yeah the
kid you don't want to eat a boiled egg
yeah I want jellybean oh it's so weird
cuz you paint it like all delicious yeah
like a like a candy color and it comes
out all salty it's kind of side to your
great yeah gross now the best part
though actual that you guys like going
hunt for eggs I love in school because
that's like you're so attentive you're
running around like really and when you
find on your like people would jump on
it get all competitive too and with some
work [ __ ] eggs never if I don't
always be a fight that breaks out too
cuz kids fight over the eggs and [ __ ]
yeah we'll find out we found like like
eggs like a week or two later
oh yeah yeah it's kinda exciting like
whoo I got the leftover eggs but like
it's been outside in the rain only now I
wanna eat that okay well in Florida
there have been reported at least half a
dozen plastic Easter eggs that have been
placed in resident mailbox that's not a
good investment
you're wasting paper on ink I mean
making money on paper on ink and the
[ __ ] Easter eggs but I still want to
find out what kind of porn is this so
these eggs were filled with random stuff
right so one cracker shaped like a fish
one toilet paper some kind of powdered
milk drink I'm sorry some kind of
powdered drink mix what is the point
where a girl shaped like a fish is that
a goldfish cracker this is a sexy fish
okay there is no Easter Egg I mean this
is what's inside the eat I mean it's
those plastic ones that you could just
throw you put things inside okay you the
fish have boobs I don't understand yeah
where's the one so you got you got the
fish you got the score toilet paper you
have powdered drink mix and a crumpled
piece of paper containing pornographic
images
oh so they ripped out like a page from a
Playboy they crumbled it up and they put
it in is Easter Egg what if this honey
and it's the black guy with the big dick
move could be that maybe they're trying
to help the people who are quarantine
they're like here's the porn here's the
tall people - come on - here all your
essentials here's why you're trying yeah
yeah you didn't run out of juices you
got a protein mix yeah first I thought
your sailor leaving Easter eggs and porn
like you never want to find the
discovery oh my god oh I like that how
many views you get or if you do that for
like our videos and you're like hey like
there's the Easter egg in here somewhere
you got to find them and then when you
find it you get to give them porn have
you been seeing the [ __ ] face mask
porn like pop-up card virus pipe never
click one yes thumbnail of a girl riding
a dude with the face mask on
yeah you frequent that porn yeah is that
supposed to be hot they'd like to be
popping there's just topical I just are
they copying on each other well I didn't
click it I didn't it's just ah why are
you bringing it out cos porn consuming
come on ball I'll check it tonight and
I'll let you know apparently there was
one Easter Egg where with a porn pic
they had like a religious brochure with
it - oh you can pray off my head for
sure I think the red or blue pill you
want to pray right now you want watch
the importance already saw regular
blu-ray which one you want mm-hmm so in
this article the police or the sheriff
was saying that this person whoever
decided to spread Easter eggs out to
people's mailboxes could be spreading oh
my god yeah that's dangerous man did you
guys hear about the guy that coughed on
a grocery worker and he was like I have
Colvin he coughed on it as a joke yeah
are we just taking you can get arrested
for that it's a funky yeah I've heard
about like this Amazon worker coughing
on people's packages because she felt
like it wasn't right that he was the
only one suffering from it what what I
don't know how true it is the
so this is one of the things away your
mom sends you to scare friends mom it's
my that thing but see I don't know how
true it is but I'm saying my
girlfriend's mom says me so much [ __ ]
any information that comes from my send
you [ __ ] like [ __ ] suck why are you I
feel like they get all their like
[ __ ] information on [ __ ] what's
that the the chat that they use yeah no
it's not what it line Oh we chat yeah
and then they get all these links from
their friends and [ __ ] that's like fake
news that's so cute
it always has the worst resolution when
they send you a picture cuz it's been
like crammed down into another person
crammed down into another person so by
that time they get to you the images are
hilarious pictures yeah there was one
time where my boyfriend's mom sent me a
link about a robbery happening outside
of 85° this is like months ago right and
she was like yeah you gotta be careful
when you go out and like to that bakery
and I was like let me see this video let
me look into this and I looked into it
it was in a completely different state
oh my ghostess Roland I was like yeah
but this exact video is on another
article with a more credible new source
saying that it was from there she was
like oh my friend lied to me and I was
like or you liked her you lied to
yourself I got this video where this guy
walks up to a car and then he licks the
bars walks away because who would
actually lick the handlebars of a car I
seen people that are doing crazy [ __ ]
there's a clip of a guy in Canada he got
into an argument with this storekeeper
and on his way out he was like [ __ ] you
in it with to the door handles like you
starts licking like the [ __ ] door
handle and everything and he walks off
and there was like definitely contracted
Cova some asses out there the co v
challenge I saw with this girl she would
try to make it populous what she live
yeah airplane yeah
this one doctor filler so themes the
white girl right did she go on dr. Phil
first or does she go viral
I went violent it was dr. feel like so
why did you decide to lick the toilet
seat over and she's like I'm not afraid
people are hyping up too much like I
don't care if I get it I'm refined and
he's like well are you worried about
like spreading it to other people she's
like no no every everyone wants to do
something so stupid because it had
nothing just to go on dr. Phil and they
become famous but they think they're
gonna go like was I go bad Barbie yeah
cash me outside that did you hear the
kid who did it after her though so could
be it became like a tick tock thing
right so then this other kid he did that
same thing on the airplane and then he
got the co-lead really yeah she got he
came out great
they got hepatitis to licking that
toilet seat
nasty that [ __ ] is so nasty yeah al
asleep
why would you even want to put okay like
you're not for the virus but still
poopoo
yeah like that's the nasty thing just to
lick why would you want to put that out
like I did that I'm not afraid of it but
like no but you're still looking that's
true that's like okay I had a [ __ ]
Slurpee it's like that's nothing to be
proud of bro this is young people
surprise nobody caught this dude like
with like every I feel like every house
now has like nest or some [ __ ]
surveillance [ __ ] nobody caught anything
well this is New Zealand right I know in
Florida New Zealand it's practicing safe
Easter eggs Oh what like you're just
being at home like having Easter egg
hunt in their house you know like
keeping it if this goes on for so long
and like it goes in so like say like
Halloween like don't jinx it Halloween
is canceled do know know but people are
people are stupid they're still gonna go
out following they're gonna have the
party is it gonna for sure people are
still having like house parties yeah
we're still having it so annoying my
neighbors yeah they're so loud they're
not even like trying to be discreet it's
like you're hearing keep it going
because I feel bad no he's like I was
young once
yeah my girlfriend once a she's like I
want to call the cops on them I'm like
it's still like 10 p.m. it's okay
well 10 p.m. is the actual noise don't
have midnight no it's not about the
noise it's it's the the people gathered
I know so it's like they're just making
it worse for everyone yeah people that
are breaking these things though get
some hardcore [ __ ] Co vide and some
other [ __ ] like this has extra credit
like you get that and hepatitis you
can't see the dentist and a broken
[ __ ] garbage disposal and a broken
[ __ ] toilet yup
cuz the plumbers not coming over no
that's how we punish these fools oh yeah
your heater's broke it to [ __ ] oh yeah
but I hope nobody in your family
actually dies and suffers real
consequences because that sucks even if
you're stupid
[Music]